this war of five Kings means nothing the
true war lies to the north my king hey
youtubers it's Charlie welcome to my
game of Thrones Season 4 preview for
Stannis and Melisandre that's right I'm
combining them into one video just
because the characters spent so much
time together in books three four and
five so spoiler warning for everything
from seasons 123 and the end of book 3
as well as the beginning of book for
let's do a quick season 3 recap of
Stannis at Dragonstone because it kind
of gives us a really clear picture of
what's going to happen with him and the
characters around him in season 4 if you
remember the onion night was getting
ready to get executed for setting Gendry
free they were going to use him to try
and raise that stone dragon but they got
a raven from the Nights Watch which
basically told them all about the
invasion of the White Walkers and their
army of whites so Melisandre basically
said that the war for the crown was
meaningless by comparison so Stannis
basically committed his forces to the
wall obviously that's going to play out
and they'll have to travel all the way
from Dragonstone to Eastwatch so I'm
guessing that probably won't happen
until about the middle of the season but
george RR martin is actually writing one
of those first couple of episodes so
that could be it because the show is
combining so many things from books for
and books 3 i'm guessing that they're
going to also condense some of the
battles because there are several
battles that happen at the wall there's
that battle between the wildlings and
the Nights Watch and then there's when
Stannis arrives there's another battle
then so I'm guessing they're going to
combine those two battles into one
battle and I'm thinking that that's the
episode that george RR martin is writing
one of the really big things in season 4
2 will be an expanded role for mil
Sandra once they get to the wall
remember they're basically trying to
prepare to fight this supernatural force
that's the enemy of her God he's
basically called the great other and Mel
Sanders one of the few people who
actually has information on him
eventually I think Sam will kind of gain
a lot of that knowledge through maester
training but I don't think that's going
to happen until winds of winter I would
expect that we're probably even going to
get a first person shot of Melisandre
staring into the flames now it's not
like looking through a telescope it's
not like she sees exactly what's going
to happen in the future but she does get
a lot of big sign posts so she doesn't
say a lot of cryptic things just to be a
pain to people it's just that she's
trying to interpret what she sees to
remember Stannis really needs to unite
the forces at the wall so once he gets
there he's going to have a really hard
time trying to get the wildlings and the
Nights Watch to make peace along with
the third force of his army so you
basically have like three different
armies the big part of season four is
going to be uniting those three groups
to fight the White Walkers speaking of
the wall once they get their mail sander
also takes a really creepy interest in
Jon Snow it's really funny because
remember she spent all that time with
Gendry so think of all those creepy sex
things that she had with Gendry and I
don't think that's going to happen with
Jon Snow just because it doesn't happen
in the books but I think it'll be
implied it'll just be really funny a lot
of people in the fandom feel like Jon
Snow is going to play this epic role in
the battle against the White Walkers and
Melisandre has previously stated that
Stannis is who she believes as aura high
is he's basically like the mythical
figure in the mythology of the great
other and the red God who's going to
lead the forces of good against the
forces of evil but a lot of people think
that that might be Jon Snow I don't
think any that's going to play out in
season 4 but Melisandre is definitely
going to stay some things that will make
you think that remember Melisandre is
still trying to raise that stone dragon
2 so she's going to need royal blood
obviously I don't think she's going to
try and sacrifice Jon Snow but there are
a couple of people at the wall with
royal blood so expect that to happen in
season 4 someone will be sacrificed it
might not play out exactly the way
Melisandre plans it but someone will go
under the knife be careful the night is
dark and full of terrors and knife
wielding red women but let me know what
you think is going to happen in season 4
remember they're changing a lot of
things from books 3 and 4 so you're
going to have to try and combine some of
the events from those together since so
many of you have requested it my next
season 4 preview will be for Theon or
reek depending on what you want to call
him it's going to be really really
creepy with him in season 4 so if you
really liked his scenes in season 3 it's
going to be even worse be sure to
subscribe to get that video i'll try and
post it on wednesday in the meantime you
can learn all about the warcraft movie i
did a big update you can click here to
watch that or you can click here to
watch my other game of thrones season
for previews thank you so much you guys
are amazing high fives